the hungarian hollywood actress zsa zsa
gabor has died at the age of 99 her
husband confirmed she passed away at her
home after suffering a heart attack well
joining me now from Hollywood is showbiz
correspondent Jeannie war from jeanie
thanks so much for joining us this one
is some real sad news and she did live
to a good old age dying from that heart
attack but she had a lot of other health
problems didn't she yes she was in
trouble for a long time a car accident
age a stroke and people weren't going to
see her but she just she wasn't all
there she really wasn't there you know
when I heard she died I got a moment of
sadness and then I thought darling
wherever she is there's champagne
flowing and there's excitement she her
last years were were not good but she
had one of the new cheese she put a book
once called one life is not enough and
she proved it she just was an amazing
woman when you say how long he is
weren't good she she had her a leg
amputated and she was suffering from
severe dementia yes well her husband
never totally confirmed exactly we know
she had her leg amputated and they were
pretty secretive about how much she was
aware of they didn't like to talk about
it you know she was very he and she were
very conscious of her image and her
image you can see I put the sparkles on
tonight I thought Josh would say dress
up for me her image was glamour and fun
and winking and and flirting and teasing
people love to have her on talk shows
and game shows she always had something
witty to say and she's always kind of
like slightly shocked you I mean towards
later on in her career she became more
known for her for her personal life
incredible personal life I mean married
nine times and had relationships of the
likes of sheep we will she said Sean
Connery and Frank Sinatra something she
revealed in her autobiography yes that
was terrible even write about Hervey she
actually had lists
list of husbands listen error of lovers
a list of famous friends but she knew
what she was about and some of that was
people like to make fun of Jojo but the
one who really like to make fun of Josh
I was herself she knew that she posed a
certain kind of figure and you remember
when when they took her to jail for
slapping a policeman she the court
papers listed her not as actress but as
celebrity she really was one of the
first people who was famous for being
famous just charismatic and what
director said I don't care if she can
act she makes love to the camera and
that makes us all feel great but she
disappeared from public life say in the
mid-90s and and rent things really did
get quite troubled for her from there
and she lost her her only child her
daughter just last year she lost her
daughter last year actually I saw
Francesco her daughter a few weeks
before she died she was a very troubled
young woman things were never right with
her in jajajaja I loved her but there
was a kind of mother-daughter jealousy
and then when Francesca did a stand-up
comedy act she kind of made fun of her
mother but in the end Joshua was really
known more as being a party girl as
being someone who kind of set the
standards for spark balling and you have
to keep using the word glamour I was
around Jojo on a shoot we did once at
Adam at a spa first we videotaped her in
a bathtub and she knew exactly where to
spread the bubbles so that was
provocative and then we had her sit down
at dinner and you know a TV kind of fake
dinner and we asked oh the manager of
the spa who is a handsome guy in a suit
I asked him to sit with her and he was
in a state of shock because she was
ordering everybody around and telling
everybody what to do and saying more
caviar please and tell you everybody
where to put the camera but i can tell
you i think it was the most exciting day
of this guy's life you could say that
she was hot tempered you could say that
she really
acted at her best when she was the one
in the spotlight but she made things
exciting and vzyal and just bubbly for
everybody and she came almost font from
nowhere didn't she i mean coming from a
quite humble life from from hungary she
came from hungry her her sister Ava came
here at first and told her about
wonderful life and in you know in
America her mother Jolie was a jewelry
dealer I met her another character with
the thick accent and rings is beautiful
like doorknobs she and her sisters were
schooled in the idea of pleasing men and
Josh I made no bones about that she was
looking for love but she was also
looking for diamonds and rubies and all
the things she considered Oh were a
girl's best friend she she loved to make
fun of her so she said of course I'm a
great housekeeper I keep every every
house from every husband I had